it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week is looking a
little sparse but if you're done with
the witcher and batman and you're
looking for something new on playstation
well they got a surprise with whispering
willows on ps4 and Vita in this
adventure game you play as Elena a
determined young girl with an
extraordinary ability to project her
spirit outside of her body in this
spectral form she can interact with
benevolent spirits and wicked rapes that
dwell within the walls of the sinister
willows mansion so it's basically Casper
solve puzzles help lost spirits and
uncover the mystery behind her missing
father so basically Casper whispering
willows is launching on june thirtieth
as a PlayStation cross by console
exclusive
the latest version of Arc System Works
2d fighting game is coming to
playstation 4 xbox one and playstation 3
and Vita this week blazblue chrono
phantasma extend gets updates to the
guard gauge system new additions in
stylish mode and the introduction of
remix heart a comedic addition to the
story mode starring to high school girls
and you also get new characters Celica
and lambda as well as new stages and
scenarios currently listed at gamestop
for fifty bucks you can pick up the
extended version on the 30th speaking of
fighting games j-stars victory vs mixed
way to Europe and North America from
Japan this week j-stars victory let's up
to four players battle it out against
one another using a gameplay and
graphical style similar to those of
Dragon Ball Z Zhen Chi battle royale
which works out well sings how you can
play as Frieza fighters can move and
fight in all directions on a 3d
battlefield and learn the layout and
land their opponents and character style
to win coming out on ps3 ps4 and Vita
you can pick it up for 60 bucks on the
30th
what else what else lego minifigures
online is coming to mobile devices this
week most likely due to the surge in
lego popularity from the beloved lego
movie this lego licensed MMO which was
originally developed for PC is making
its way to your phone lego minifigures
online will offer the ability for cross
play between platforms to make sure you
can have fun with everyone so an apple
iOS user can be in the same game as a
Windows PC player or a google android
gamer so you can at least be together
fans of the lego franchise will be able
to download lego minifigures online for
499 with additional worlds being
available through in-app purchases the
pc version costs 2999 but should just
get everything straight up that's out on
the 29 okay what else all right uh what
else well uh okay we're gonna go with
unpossible a 3d endless runner releasing
on steam this week with various game
modes from simplicity to ultra
unpossible you dodge obstacles forever
on an endless track to some beats well
there you go for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change
you